what's up everybody this is john cho and
i'm going undercover on the internet
this is actually me
[Music]
reddit
[Music]
there is a picture of me wearing
sunglasses walking through our new
tijuana set on cowboy bebop and this
tobe pickvida asks will he have
a fake eye i didn't know that
spike had a fake eye
i wasn't aware of any eye trauma but um
he does have the thing in his shades
shadowrancher asks did they cut ed the
ed's there
or that's a secret we didn't
watch the show it's yeah snyder863 asks
where are the cigarettes the cigs have
to be there that's non-negotiable all
the main characters smoke and they smoke
a lot cigarettes matter beyond looking
cool and generally aligning with the
bebop's crews i don't give a [ __ ] vibe
the cigs tell you they've made mistakes
they're tortured by their pasts
they don't particularly care what
happens to them in the future cutting
out the cigarettes actually compromises
the character of the series
calm down that's cool we can get rid of
the cigarettes
twitter
uh-oh ronaldo trancoso says searching is
an intense thriller with a cool twist
and a terrific performance from john cho
wow
this guy's
insightful why no one told me it's so
devastating the first scenes remind me
of up
it was a real uh inspiration for that
opening sequence the the sequence he's
referring to is um
really ingenious um storytelling method
where we go through his character's
computer
and
see from his changing calendar
what's going on in his life anyway
here's another movie
norma jean
asks so with this asian-american
renaissance of the rom-com i ask you i
beg of you why hasn't john cho starred
in one yet
that's a good question maybe i'm too hot
to get the girl like it's it seems so
inevitable
that i would land the hottest woman on
earth that
it doesn't seem narratively fulfilling
it's the only explanation i can think of
cindy lau evans asks i would ask john
cho what additional movie poster would
you like to see as part of hashtag
starring joncho gallery ooh i have i
have seen it and heard of a hashtag
starring joncho and will you started
mocking up on photoshop posters uh with
me in it um
i guess i would like to be hey let's go
old school uh casablanca
titanic you know where i'm posing for
the painting
it's a gender joke it's not cool tim
underscore chan asks will there be
another harold and kumar i gotta say
that this is a
really stupid answer
uh but you know we used to have a lot of
political jokes and
race jokes and i don't know what
the movie can do now i don't know how to
navigate that we're giving it some
thought
but it is like a much more complicated
endeavor than it was five years ago but
i'd like to i really like everyone and i
like the characters fingers crossed
right your congressman
wikipedia
joe gained attention with a small role
as milk guy number two in the 1999
comedy american pie
in which he popularized the slang term
milf
this is true all of it is
true except the adjective small
for role that was the first time i'd
heard
the the term milf and um
it didn't turn out to be the last time i
heard it the last time was
yesterday
yelled at me at extreme volume at a
trader joe's
i can't tell you how much of my social
media comments are just people
posting the word milf could be martin
luther king day comments
milf it could be happy world adoption
day everybody comments
milf happy refugee day comment you get
the idea
in 2006 and again in 2009 cho was
selected as one of the sexiest men alive
in people magazine i i feel like it was
once was it twice
if it's in wikipedia i'm guessing it's
true yes
scientists were right
that's why you can't do it
that's right
he is close to his father a former
preacher and would like to play a role
in the story of his father generation
growing up in north korea through the
korean war uh this is true i would love
to be a part of telling that that story
it's certainly fascinating and um
personally important to me so yes that
is a resounding yes all right let's see
some youtube comments
highlighted comment from hadir dear east
asians i'm a west asian fellow can you
tell me the secret for your killer skin
dude he's 46 in this video 46 and a
series of faces what are those faces
those i'm dead i okay so here's my
regimen it's uh it starts with a
kilogram of turmeric that i put all over
and then
it's uh it's it's a tomatillo sauce 20
minutes under a hot towel and then you
douse that towel in merlot it doesn't
have to be high quality merlot just
merlot any merlot enjoy
shower twice
go about your day
rachel hall said wow
ryan reynolds is a white version of john
cho he tells me he gets that a lot he
gets it all
the time so you're on to something
rachel hall dan hammond smith am i the
only one annoyed he didn't list
stiffler's mom oh i get it i get it i
was supposed to list
what i couldn't live without
stiffler's mom
dan
you did it
tick tock tick tock are you on tick tock
do you have
i have a lot of tick-tock accounts i
have a lot it's weird that you asked me
that celebrities that auditioned for the
office john cho we could have had john
chio jim jianjo jim we could have had
giancho jim um yeah
i don't think it was uh
anywhere in the realm of possibility but
i am very honored to have auditioned for
the office it is far and away
uh the my favorite television show and i
think i'm gonna say
it's the third greatest show
ever
one is i love lucy because it invented
the form i had cheers number two
because of how long it went and how good
it was
for how many different cast members it
had
but i'm thinking maybe it's
office has to do be number two but they
lost steve carrell for the last two
seasons
and it wasn't as good in season eight
i'd say begrudgingly so
i'm gonna give cheers a slight edge
but office is number three and coming in
strong
cingo bachera asks why did harold never
make it in hollywood what does that mean
because it is accompanied by a
disgusting picture of myself with
a slider in my mouth is it talking about
the character or me
i guess if it's me it's a it's either
sarcastic
or a bummer
instagram
i teach artists says y'all i can't my
heart is going to burst so many great
actors and actresses here but where's
the puppy the puppy's there okay the
puppy's [ __ ] there chill you think we
wouldn't put the [ __ ] puppy in you
think we're that dumb
god
thank you for your support though it's
really sweet of you to post
anna's chirad hey john cho fans i have a
question does anyone know where i can
find chords for any viva la union songs
i'll i'll i'll reach out to you later my
phone number
lady810 asks into this picture i posted
with cherushi who's one of the stars of
parasite she says please make a movie
together i would love to make a movie
with him i'm thinking a buddy
cop
movie
um so he's a cop from korea and i'm an
american cop we don't like each other
we're not getting along sort of rush
hour but two koreans what do you guys
think
korean american who's never been to
korea within ghost korea to be a cop
and has a cultural
identity issue of like
being korean but never having been in
korea i think i like that we'll shoot it
in korea i think yeah yeah i'm fish out
of water yeah
quora
what is quora
how did joncho hurt his knee in filming
cowboy bebop just a weird freak accident
because it wasn't uh it was something
i'd done like 10 times i asked the
doctor a bunch of what what were wrong
and it was really hard to say and um so
everybody take you out there
because
weird things happen would watching
harold and kumar adequately prepare me
for consuming
marijuana
prepare
i feel like uh
you prepare by doing the marijuana
and then watch the movie i feel like the
sequence is wrong here no
okay that's it i'm signing off the
internet thanks guys that was a weird
mixture of ego pumping and ego deflation
this has been
actually me
by gq